um
great
right
so
thank you for having me i hope this will
not fall off
all right thank you for having me um
today i'm going to be talking about uh
causal effects
in mpdax and mostly focus on the
efficient estimation part here
and the linear setting
just trying to figure out how i don't
get the
right uh this is joint work with richard
guo who is here and he gets all the
credit for like all the great results we
have uh
yes
okay sure
no worries
all right uh so
some of you may have seen some versions
of this talk previously i apologize for
that
i have also given a talk in simons for
people who have been longer term earlier
here if you've seen that dog that talk
that should be helpful for understanding
maybe some pointers here if you haven't
you should not worry about it it should
not be necessary
okay great
right so and also some slides may seem
familiar in that case okay great so the
goal for us is we want to estimate some
total causal effect
of some x a on some x y so x a for us
will be treatment some type of treatment
and x y will be the response
and ideally right you want to do this
from randomized control study data
where you intervene and set xa to a
certain value and then monitor kind of
the change that happens in the response
as kind of
the result of that uh setting right so
i'll use this notation of do
interventions so do x a means that you
have an intervention that sets these
variables to some fixed value xa
and
the issue for us will be that we will
want to use observational data to
compute this rather than randomized
control studies data
and the major challenge there is that
this interventional distribution of the
response is different
than this observational kind of quantity
uh here
okay great
okay so
how can we kind of do this so i will use
this
graph kind of as a running example
throughout
and i'm going to assume right this is a
causal direct base i could graph so
acyclic means there's no feedback loops
and additionally each of the nodes in
this graph represents a random variable
and each of the edges in my graph will
be a direct causal effect
right so if i change a it will affect b
in some way and so on
additionally throughout i will assume
i'm interested in the causal effect of a
on y
and throughout i'm going to assume that
a just is like a single variable and y
is a single variable that is not
required for this results to go through
but it just makes things simpler to talk
about
okay
all right so if you have observational
data you kind of have data that comes
from this graph and we want to use that
data to
kind of estimate our causal effect
and if we were to have the data from a
randomized control trial then the data
would come from a graph that kind of
looks like this right where you've kind
of intervened your set a to some fixed
value so now this e no longer can impact
a but whatever you've set a to can still
kind of propagate downstream from a
all right
so we don't have data from this we have
data from this but we want to kind of
pretend as if we have i guess data from
this and still be able to estimate the
total causal effect
and this is like the notation slide
right so
so what
what i'm going to use here so i'm going
to assume we have this intervention that
says variables
x8 to some fixed value a
and then i'm going to talk about
something like an observational
distribution and an interventional
distribution and i will say that a dag
is causal
if this observational distribution but
also the interventional distribution all
factorize according to this back
right so this observational distribution
factorizes in this way so it's each node
given its parent nodes and the
interventional distribution factorizes
in kind of exactly the same way except
that you drop the term that depends on a
so in this simple graph here this is
what that implies right so in this
interventional distribution we just kind
of lose this term but this term here
matches this term here and this first
term matches
the first term on this
now in this project i will additionally
assume
that my data is generated by a linear
causal model
which in this case would be something
like this so in the observational case i
have this linear causal model so
right so xa is a function of xb plus
some error so it's some edge weight here
on this edge plus some error and y is
then equal to some
constant right gamma a b y times x b
plus gamma a y times x a plus some error
term in the interventional setting i
will just
choose to set my xa to a fixed value and
that will then propagate also downstream
so additionally i'm assuming that these
errors here
are
mutually independent have mean zero and
some constant
and the finite variance
great
and by the way i will refer to this as a
structural causal model or scm so sem
for me a structural causal model not
synthetic control model
like in the previous two dogs
all right
great so
how do i define a total causal effect
so total causal effect can be defined as
some change in the response right due to
this treatment and so in this linear
setting it makes sense to define it in
this way so it's kind of this difference
between these expectations of x y in one
intervention
and exploitation of x under that
different intervention where like these
differences are just changed by one
in the linear case this is also
equivalent of kind of just taking this
derivative
of the expectation with respect to xa
i will say that the total causal effect
is identifiable for observational data
if you can express this distribution as
a function of this observational
distribution
so
now if you've seen the previous talk or
the previous slide you know that if i
give you a causal bag then you can
identify every total causal effect right
so we have this interventional
distribution
of y is just a marginal of the joint
interventional distribution
and we already know how that factorizes
in terms of uh in terms of the dag if we
have the causal back so this so you can
identify this effect in this way and
then you can plug it into this
computation to kind of compute your
total causal effect actually this is
something that i will call the g formula
generalized g formula truncated
factorization formula manipulation that
should be whatever you like i will call
it the g g5
additionally
sometimes you can identify these causal
effects through a different formula
in particular i will talk a little bit
about adjustment
so with adjustment so if you have a set
z that satisfies certain conditions
it will be an adjustment set which means
for us that this interventional
distribution can be expressed in exactly
this way
and so these two formulas will induce
two different estimators of the causal
effects and i'll do some comparison of
these two essentially
all right
so let's go back to our
our graph
so here i'm assuming now the data is
generated by in matrix form this system
right so i have x times this
gamma matrix where this element gamma i
j is non-zero
or is zero if you don't have that i is a
parent of j
so the only allowed non-zeros are the
ones where
a is a parent of b and b is parent of c
and so on
okay so same all of the same
things we had before
okay great and we are interested in the
total effect of a and y so the total
effect for us it just means that it
propagates through these edges on this
causal path from a to y
and so in this linear setting
we know even from right
back in the early days that by kind of
path tracing rules and using that gamma
matrix we had on the previous slide you
can express this total causal effect as
these sum products of these edge weights
right so it will be kind of this gamma a
b times gamma bc time gamma c y plus
gamma c times gamma c y
right and also by g formula
right we can just plug in what the g
formula is here and that kind of
actually also gives us
the same computation
so this g formula kind of based
estimator if you look at this is the
expectation of x y given x c and x c
same same thing for this gamma c y this
suggests kind of a plug-in estimator
where you estimate essentially all of
the elements of your matrix gamma
by regressing each node on its parents
from that you get your estimates for the
little gamma cy so you get the little
gamma cy hat you get a little gamma bc
hat and so on
and you can plug that in and get your
tau uh a y hat
right so that's what the g formula kind
of suggests you should do based on on
this formulation here
right now in this case for this
particular graph we can also estimate
this effect and identify and estimate
this effect in a different way so we
here know that this e
it's a common cause of a and y it's the
only common cause so it's an adjustment
set so if you adjust for e
right if you kind of block this path
through e you will also get the causal
effects so since this is an adjustment
this is an adjustment set you can also
kind of look at this causal effect
as uh computing it through this formula
and what this formula here would suggest
to you in terms of an estimator is an
estimator where
you
estimate
this
total effect as the least squares
coefficient in just this regression of y
on a and e so that's where the
adjustment
name comes from it's just an adjusted
regression for e
right and so what we were i guess
thinking about
is which of these estimators is more
efficient in the setting
and what happens if you don't know the
causal back
all right
so which estimator is more efficient
this is kind of a question that's been
thought about uh
for a long time it's not uh nothing new
so if you assume uh gaussian errors and
you assume you know the causal bag
then there's work by hayashi and karaoke
for example that says that this path
trades in estimator so the plug-in where
you kind of estimate each of the gammas
and plug that in that is more efficient
than any of the covariate adjustment
methods that you can use
right it's also not surprising because
in this in this case that just happens
to be the plug-in mle estimator right
so that's
not super surprising
but what happens if you don't know the
dac so i guess this is where our
curiosity was peaked and also you know
you don't have to assume gaussian errors
so what if we do not know the dag so
this is kind of the setting where i
usually i guess work in
that this is not something if you have a
linear gaussian data that you can learn
just from data
so from that data you could use a
structure like this and i don't know if
people can see that these are gray
directed there or still
and then all of the other
edges here are undirected so this is a
graph known as completed partially
directed they cycle the graph or a cp
dag
and as you can see it has both
undirected and directed edges and the
undirected edges mean here that we don't
know whether this is like a causes c or
c causes a in the underlying deck
you can think about this as a summary
graph representing an equivalence class
of graphs and one of these is your true
puzzle tag you just don't know which one
it is
right so now additionally i'm going to
add some domain knowledge so let's say i
will add the domain knowledge that e
causes a
and i will propagate this knowledge
using the assumption that my underlying
graph is a dag so acyclic
and certain other
rules so using these orientation rules
of make i'll propagate this knowledge to
get some more orientations right
so now i have something called a
maximally oriented partially directed
acyclic graph or an mp dag
that represents essentially something
you can learn from observational data
and perhaps some domain knowledge
and so on
all right so this still has some
undirected edges so it still represents
an equivalence class of graphs now it's
just a kind of a shrunken down version
of the original equivalence class of
graphs yes
you're claiming that all these
arrows are consequences of e to a edge
yes
yes and that's what i'm saying
so here the reason that they're all
implied because if you have had the
arrow pointing the other way you would
have another b structure and that would
apply some additional conditional
independencies so where will you make
the assumptions about these structures
[Music]
so a cv bag
kind of is uniquely identified if you
know uh its skeleton and you know these
v structures so here this is a b
structure what that means is just that
you have both of these pointing into y
but they themselves e and c are not
adjacent okay so implicit in in all
these undirected edges is that there's
no restructures yes
right
great
so we are here
awesome and so we are wondering kind of
what do you do here
how do you identify and estimate effects
efficiently here
right
so in my big framework slide we are in
this part this is where our interests
are
so the idea is we have some
observational data and perhaps some
background knowledge that we
have used in
the past to learn this causal graph i i
do assume that i have no latent
variables which is a very strong
assumption and uh
one that i would like to get rid of at
some point
so this causal graph for us can be a
dark cpw or an mp deck but just note
that this ampy dag kind of is a bigger
class of graphs that subsumes these
other two so you can think about a cpu
tag as kind of an empty dag where the
background knowledge you added was like
not informative at all and a dag where
this background knowledge was fully
informative of the causal structure
you can also kind of think about this
picture slightly differently which is
that you started from a dag
right that that you believe is kind of
true but perhaps you're not sure about
some orientations so you remove them
from your graph and that's how so you
start it from a dag and remove some
information that's how you write it up
with an empty lag so either way you
think about this it's it's fine
and right we want to use this graph to
uh well identify and then estimate
estimated all causal effect so
so i will focus on this efficient
estimation so i will assume that my
effect is already identified and
to to do that i will use a result
previous result
okay so here is the results so we've so
far talked about dax and i've shown you
kind of the adjustment stuff in dax and
this g formula index as well
now there are criterions that allow you
to kind of identify all valid adjustment
sets in these cpdx and mpdex as well
and this previous result that i
mentioned that just generalized this g
formula to these cpdx and mpx right
so now we can use these two uh kind of
estimators in both of these cases and
knowing what we know from that we are i
guess expecting this formula this kind
of way of estimating things to be more
efficient than the adjustment form so
that's i guess our claim to fame
another thing
to know is that this adjustment here
in also of these three graphs is kind of
sufficient for identification it's not
necessary particularly if you have for
example
sequential treatments where one
treatment affects the other treatment
you often will not be able to estimate
those that joint effect with adjustment
but you can still use the g-form
okay great so let's talk about kind of
previous results so there are several
results uh actually on a comparing
estimation here so henkel at all avite
at all and redness can smuggler
they all graphically characterize what
would be kind of an optimal covariate
adjustment set in all of these graphs
right so if you just limit yourself to
just estimators that are based on
adjustment
what is the best estimator to use in
terms of efficiency so they all actually
agree on just one type one definition of
which is the best adjustment
however as pointed out by kind of these
arrows
implication versus kind of equivalence
covariate adjustment is not complete for
estimating all identifiable causal
effects
so the question is can we kind of
leverage this kind of new result that
generalizes the g formula to get kind of
better efficiency in the case uh of cpdx
and mpdx
right
and so
now we go back to our linear system
right so this was our original back
and now i'm moving to this world of an
empty deck where i don't know the the
orientation of these two edges
now what happens to our system here
right previously what we wanted to do
is just kind of estimate all the
elements of this gamma and then do a
plug-in estimator based on based on
these
parts but now our gamma is not
identifiable because we don't know kind
of these orientations we don't know
which gammas should be zero which ones
should be non-zeros essentially
so i'm going to
rewrite this problem into something that
will then give me a solution
i'll say okay let's consider what are
these buckets
which is just a short word
to use instead of this thing which is
the maximal undirected connective
components in this epidemic
right so what are the buckets here so
i'll just remove all the oriented edges
so that we know and so now our buckets
are
these four so e
a there's a single
node buckets and then bcd is a triple
and y and so they're ordered here in the
topological order in the causal ordering
in the graph right so e comes before a
and so on
okay great so now i know that between
these buckets
i have all of the edges oriented
and actually
in this previous paper
that implies to me that these effects
between the buckets should be
identifiable the causal effects between
within the vacuums the causal effects
are unidentifiable because i mean
obviously i don't know where their b
causes c or c causes b
and there's also another nice property
here which we
exploit to get our result
which is
what richard's called a restrictive
property which is that each node in a
bucket has the same set of out-of-bucket
parents
what that means here is that a if a is a
parent of b it also must be apparent of
everything else in this kind of
maximal and directed connected component
all right so i'll use that to rewrite
my
linear structural causal model
great
okay so i'll just
take all of those x's that belong to one
bucket and i'm going to split the gamma
coefficients
into the coefficients that come from
the out of bucket parents into the
bucket
and all of the other coefficients so
this will contain like all of the
coefficients within the bucket right
so for example if i look at my bcd
bucket this part will just be all of
these
gammas and this part will hide all of
these within bucket gaps
so that's the only thing happening here
and we still have our errors on the on
the whole bucket
and so now you can notice that i have an
xbi here and i have an xbi there so i'm
just going to put them together and i'm
going to invert this i minus
gamma b i i can do that because there is
a right this is an exactly graph so this
matrix can be triangular
if you if you choose the right ordering
and so now i have
this
times the x out of bucket parents plus
this term which multiplies our upper
error term
and now i'm just going to rename the
things here into this will be called
like lambda out of bucket parents bucket
complicated thing to say still times x
uh parents of out of bucket parents plus
these new var epsilon errors now which
hides kind of all this ugly stuff here
right okay and so this is something that
holds for each of these buckets
and so i've just written it out for one
and now we're going to put it all
together to get like back our
entire structural causal model right
so i'll just
use i'll just kind of put these blocks
of these lambdas together
in the right order
to get back this system so now x is
equal to lambda
transpose times x
plus this var epsilon
so yes chris
the calculation on the last slide yeah
um i just want to try and follow here
where did the i see an x on the right on
the yeah on the right hand side the top
equation
bi and i've seen ex parents
uh how did that come together to be
ex-parents oh where did the xbi go or is
that something about this one moved to
this side that gave you this thing times
xbi
and then i just inverted that and
multiplied with this with this part
right so this part comes from here
and these and this gives you kind of
this does that make sense
is it a quality or is is that
is that
oh sorry oh yeah absolutely uh yeah yeah
i i see what you're saying yes i i
messed it up a little bit so i could
yeah
okay that's fine
yes yes uh yes i could expand on this a
little bit the quality here
yeah yeah well that's true
great thanks for
i will fix that in the in the final
version of the slides
great uh
okay so we can rewrite our structural
causal model into this form
so what has changed now so now we have
that this
lambda ij elements they are zero
for everything so if you have i j such
that i is not an out of bucket parent of
j
and another thing that has changed is
that for these var epsilon errors we
still have that their mean zero
but uh now
you know they're no longer kind of
mutually independent within the bucket
but between the different bucket
components they are mutually independent
and so that's helpful so this is this is
really helpful
okay great
uh so under this re-parametrization we
get a few nice things so one if you
choose s to be kind of all the nodes
that are ancestors of y
uh not through a
then this total causal effect can
actually be expressed just in this like
kind of simple simplish form i guess
right so it's these elements
lambda a s
times this times s y
or if you prefer you can say
i just want to estimate all the elements
of my lambda and then do kind of pass
tracing rules on those
so i'll come to an example of that
so another nice thing that happens is if
you have gaussian errors then these
these block components this lambda
uh parents bi bi just corresponds um
so the maximum likelihood estimator for
these just corresponds to the least
squares coefficients from these kind of
multivariate regressions of this bi on
its parents out of body parents and so
this kind of process is what we call
geo-regression
so that's the estimator we propose
it's made up of that right
so our idea is okay just estimate these
individual lambdas through this
through this type of geo-regression
estimator and then you kind of can plug
it into this to get your total effect
aspect
and then we can make this claim uh that
turns out to be true
for any consistent estimator tau uh a y
tau a y hat of tau
a y that is the differentiable function
of the sample covariance
we know that our estimator that we
propose this g regression one will kind
of have a smaller or equal asymptotic
varies
yes great perfect
i know it looks like i have a lot of
slides but it's just
i will get through it uh okay great
so these so you might wonder okay what
are these estimators so that actually
includes all of the covariate adjustment
estimators uh recursive regression
estimators from uh nandi at all and kind
of good at all as well as this modified
specialized key decomposition estimator
proposed by andy at all
so they all fall under this and our
things should be more efficient
so let's go to the example and just let
me tell you kind of what what kind of
the plan is here so now we're saying
that in this case
this total effect i can just replace
here what would be that generalized g
formula
will have this form so you have x y
given c and e
and then x xc given a
so what this is proposing to you
if you don't want to think about
estimating the entire lambda
is a plug-in estimator made up of two
coefficients right so one is so
essentially get a coefficient from the
regression of xc on a
and then you get the coefficient from uh
y on xc and e so get the coefficient
next to xc you multiply those two that
will give you
your total effect right so you can
decompose the total effect of a on y as
kind of the total effect of a on c
and the effect of c on y
and
that ends up being the
kind of efficient thing to do here
okay great so let me just briefly go
then through our simulation study so we
have
uh
simulated some results just to compare
with these other estimators that we're
claiming we're beating
asymptotically uh so we simulate a data
from a linear structural causal model
with various error types
and then we choose our a and y such that
this effect is identifiable because
that's we're starting from that
and we'll compute the squared error
because we're simulating so we can of
kind of the true value minus what our
estimate is and have that squared so
we'll do that for all of the estimators
and so we'll compare our g regression
estimator to the adjustment estimator
this ida m
which is this joint either is this
estimator based on scholeski
decomposition from the paper of joint
idea if you are familiar with that
and also compare with idar which is also
from the same paper but it's based on
what they call recursive regressions
so we draw like a lot of these violin
plots
and so
what we're putting on these violin plots
is just this uh okay so you all see
is this fraction so it's the estimation
error of this of whatever other
estimator is
divided by the g regression estimation
error
and so if it's bigger than one that
means that the g-regression estimator is
essentially doing better
so another thing to note here is that
this is we are assuming in this case i
believe that we know
the true dag
so in this simulation we're assuming we
know the true dag but we're using kind
of small
well finite samples to kind of do all of
these computations so that's why you
also see sometimes that values below one
here because our result is in a
synthetic result and obviously in
practice that will not always be true
but you can see that if you compare
with different estimators so the first
violin plot so the one on the left in
all of the plots is the adjustments the
optimal adjustment estimator the middle
one is the modified celestia
decomposition comparison and the third
one is the recursive regressions
and you can see that generally
we do better than
all of them generally
but
we do better much better than these
second two compared to the optimal
adjustments so the optimal adjustment
does actually pretty well
and of course this is all if you know
the dac
uh one thing to mention is though that
this is kind of comparison on these
instances where we could estimate the
total effect with all these methods i
believe
and uh i can be corrected if that's not
true
but there are a lot of instances where
these estimators kind of fail to
identify the effects so you cannot use
them to estimate where you can use the
gear regression estimator so this is
kind of just a
table showing that
and there are cases where for example
you cannot use this estimator to
estimate the effect even though it's
estimable
and same thing goes here and you will
see that the numbers here match numbers
here that's because they both have the
same kind of identifiability condition
even though it's a different estimate
okay and i'm out of time so this is also
given like an estimated tp rack so you
can see once you estimate we don't do as
well uh i mean the the comparison is not
as uh impressive but it's
still something
if you're wondering uh what do you do if
you don't have a linear structural
causal model then you should come see
richard stock
on wednesday uh here
at yeah at the berkeley causal inference
group because we have some work on that
that's all thank you
now um thank you emma and now we are
taking a break and we will be back at 3
30.
you